who doesn't love a crispy fried chicken
a great fried chicken should have a
crunchy exterior with deep crackly
grooves and be super flavorful and juicy
we tested a lot of fried chicken and we
mean a lot
let's get started and put this poultry
in motion tasty 101 fried chicken
[Music]
there are lots of versions of fried
chicken around the world but today we're
going to be focusing on a good old
classic american fried chicken
we're going to dry brine this chicken so
we'll mix together salt black pepper
garlic powder onion powder and some
lemon zest
dry brine works through osmosis
essentially salting the meat ahead of
time will draw out moisture from it the
moisture will break down the salt and
reabsorb into the protein this
tenderizes and flavors it throughout
another option is just buttermilk but we
didn't think it was as great as using
the dry brine we also saw lots of
recipes marinating the chicken in a
mixture of buttermilk and eggs but we
didn't notice a huge difference between
this and just marinating it in straight
up buttermilk dry vine was by far the
best option it's a foolproof way of
getting perfectly seasoned crispy tender
and juicy chicken we're going to start
by patting dry the chicken pieces with
paper towels and then we're going to
season them with the salt mixtures to
evenly coat each piece now we're going
to line a large tupperware with some
paper towels and we'll add our seasoned
chicken to it we're going to stick it in
the fridge and let it sit uncovered for
at least four hours but preferably
overnight make sure to remove your
chicken from the fridge 30 minutes
before frying pro tip
you want your chicken to be at room
temperature before frying it's important
to keep all meat and poultry chilled
before cooking for safety but it is
acceptable to let your chicken sit at
room temperature for up to 30 minutes
before frying this step also ensures
that your chicken cooks evenly and has a
superior texture you can use cast iron
to fry chicken it retains heat really
well and it stays at the temperature you
want but since it's so shallow it can
create burnt spots where the chicken is
touching the surface of the pan and oil
tends to splatter everywhere so it can
get pretty messy
stainless steel pots work too but the
heat can fluctuate a little more easily
our cookware of choice the dutch oven it
retains heat well and it's deeper so the
chicken doesn't burn as easily
let's talk about some oils
not every type of oil is suitable for
frying and it basically boils down to
the smoke point frying chicken requires
maintaining a fairly high temperature of
around 350 degrees fahrenheit or about
180 degrees celsius and not every type
of oil can withstand this heat without
scorching so make sure to check what the
smoke point of your oil is
canola or vegetable is the standard oil
to use for deep frying and it works
great its high smoke point and low level
of saturated fat make it a compelling
choice and because it's neutral in
flavor it won't impart any additional
flavors to your food
other alternatives such as peanut oil
have a higher saturated fat content so
some say it makes food crispier but we
didn't notice a big difference between
this and canola and the peanut oil is
just a little more expensive the
traditional southern way is to use
shortening or lard but their smoke point
is pretty low so it's not ideal to use
just in case you accidentally overheat
your oil for this fry we're gonna stick
with the neutral oil with a high smoke
point so we're going with canola
let's heat up our canola oil in this
large dutch oven to 350 degrees
fahrenheit or 180 degrees celsius we
tested a variety of combinations for our
coating and here's what we found you can
go old school and just use straight up
flour but it doesn't stay as crispy and
the coating pulls away from the meat
after it's cooked the all-purpose flour
and rice flour combo didn't stay crispy
after sitting out and the texture and
flavor wasn't your traditional southern
fried coating flour baking powder and
buttermilk this method is great but can
get a little messy and it doesn't always
stick to the chicken
flour and corn starches are runner-up it
came out of the oil super crispy but
didn't hold up that great after sitting
out our winner for this chicken dinner
the wet and dry double dipping method
flour and baking powder for the dry
ingredients and egg whites vodka and
buttermilk for the wet ingredients let
us show you what we mean first we're
going to combine our dry ingredients so
we'll whisk together our flour baking
powder onion powder garlic powder and
salt
now let's combine our wet ingredients so
we'll whisk together our buttermilk egg
whites and vodka the egg whites add
structure to the coating making it
crispier it also helps the flour coating
stick to the chicken like culinary glue
we tested this with whole eggs but it
made the crust softer because of the
yolk's fat content
the alcohol evaporates quickly in the
frying oil this sets the coating and
creates flaky layers you often see this
ingredient used in pie crust recipes for
the same reason if you don't want to use
vodka you can totally omit it
time to double dip we're going to dip
the brine chicken first in our flour
mixture then into the buttermilk mixture
and then back into the flour mixture
maybe it's more of a triple dip
in any case we'll shake off any excess
flour and we'll repeat with all of our
remaining chicken pieces when coating
and breading your chicken be sure to tap
off the excess buttermilk as well as the
excess flour
this method creates all those little
crackly bits and using the semi double
dip also means that you'll have a nice
layer of crust
not so thin that you barely know it's
there but also not so thick that you
need an excavator to find the chicken
inside these chicks are ready to fry
we're gonna put two or three pieces into
our hot oil and we'll cook them for
seven to ten minutes just until the
internal temperature reaches 165 degrees
fahrenheit or 75 degrees celsius
don't overcrowd your pan you want to
make sure that the chicken isn't bumping
against other pieces of chicken which
can knock off the breading the baking
powder creates these very tiny air
bubbles on the surface of the batter
chicken when it's placed in the hot oil
the bubbles expand the surface area of
the batter breaking up its thickness
which results in a lighter and crispier
fried chicken flip your chicken only
once while frying the more you fuss with
your chicken the more likely you are to
disturb some of the crunchy coating do
not move the chicken or start checking
for doneness until it's fried for at
least 3 minutes you really want to give
that coating a minute to cook do not
rely solely on visual cues for doneness
visual cues aren't always the best way
to detect when your chicken is done
cooking thermometers are your friend it
can accurately measure your oil
temperature and your chicken's internal
temperature helping you cook to
perfection every time we would recommend
a candy or deep fry thermometer to check
your oil's temperature it clips to the
pot and monitors the temperature we'll
cook these until they reach the correct
temperature and the exterior is golden
brown and crispy to accurately determine
the internal temperature we'll use a
meat thermometer that will insert into
the thickest part of the meat but we're
going to be careful to avoid the bone if
your chicken is getting too dark too
quickly don't worry you can always
finish it in the oven for better results
just heat your oven to about 375 degrees
fahrenheit about 190 degrees celsius and
cook the chicken for five to seven
minutes and you should be good to go
once our chicken's cooked we're going to
remove it from the oil and we'll
transfer it to a wire rack
do not blot the excess oil on paper
towels it's a common mistake you want to
get rid of the excess oil but if you do
it by laying the freshly fried chicken
on top of paper towels this will create
steam the moisture from the steam will
soften that crispy crust you just worked
so hard to get on your fried chicken so
to keep your crust but banish the excess
oil set your chicken on a wire cooling
rack this way the excess oil can drip
down but the chicken won't become soggy
on a moist humid surface then we'll
season it with salt
keep working around the clock and repeat
with the remaining chickens no pun in
tender
sorry not sorry
make sure to clean the oil in between
batches to prevent the bits left behind
from burning and altering the taste of
the oil that you're frying in just don't
wing it keep it clean oh man it looks so
crispy and it's so flavorful and juicy
now go ahead and enjoy your beautiful
and mouth-watering fried chicken we hope
that this video or should i say chick
flick has helped you with your fried
chicken journey if there are other types
of fried chicken you'd like for us to
fry let us know in the comments below
you